ça n'a pas tellement changé tous les
matins à 8h30 royal jespersen ouvre son
micro pour s'adresser aux libertés et
discuter des grands enjeux qui marquent
l'actualité mais il ne le fait plus à la
station de radio la plus écoutée en
alberta mais plutôt sur youtube dans son
émission rôle tank qui est ensuite
disponible en baladodiffusion une maison
l'animateur y aborde une foule de sujets
mais ce qui a permis de rendre son
émission incontournable
ce sont ces critiques du gouvernement
albertain geessink eni a été bon pour
les affaires les controverses n'ont pas
manqué à gingsheim canada une sauvegarde
député-ministre en voyage dans le sud
cet hiver ou encore difficultés à
contenir la deuxième et troisième vague
de la pandémie
royan jesse pearson canalise les
frustrations de bon nombre de ses
concitoyens interagir avec le public
fait aussi partie intégrante du concept
les auditeurs clavardent comment tout au
long de l'émission
ils sentent qu'ils sont des membres à
part entière de la petite équipe de
trois personnes est le modèle d'affaires
fonctionne l'émission tire la majorité
de ses revenus d'une vingtaine
d'entreprises qui achètent de la
publicité et les auditeurs sociaux
finance aussi le projet d'avoir aubois
ont dépendants avant d'être nommé au
sénat par la semaine sainte est
journaliste à edmonton pendant plus de
20 ans auditrice régulière et éviter à
quelques occasions
elle estime que cette émission était
arrivé à un moment crucial alors que la
pandémie bouleverser nos vies cette mi
temps où tout le monde cherche enfance
des communautés parce que nous sommes
tout seul chez nous la capacité de jesse
pearson aborder tous les sujets explique
aussi selon la sénatrice pourquoi son
émission play un auditoire toujours plus
large
un peu comme tout le monde en parle ce
n'est pas seulement une chose de les
divertir lieu dans une province
conservatrice comme l'alberta le ton et
le contenu des tonnes ci se situe lui
même plutôt centre droit de l'échiquier
politique royale j'espère surtout à son
indépendance il croit qu'il manquait une
plateforme pour les voir plus
progressistes dans la province son
succès est aussi la preuve selon lui que
l'alberta ne ressemble pas aux clichés
tenaces qui sont parfois véhiculée
ailleurs au pays
moins d'un an après son lancement le
balade où commence à prendre sa place
sur la scène nationale
c'est d'ailleurs que justin trudeau
accordé sa première entrevue au
lendemain du budget fédéral mais il
souhaite devenir la référence au pays et
il voit grand
d'ailleurs il quittera bientôt son
premier studio pour quelque chose de
plus spacieux ici mathieu cueilli un
radio canada center